[Music]
Ah
uh um dem In
a word, in the new year,
Phil Ga Muk 5
[Music]
Uh
[Music] I am going to
sing my body
.
Expression of the virtual universe 1 minute
[Music]
Ordinary people think that it is a brave thing to become Seohee. It's
just a picture frame that is made and quietly I
think.
No, Suae is a real living Jesus
.
It's Hongje. Nice to meet you.
I was in 4th grade of elementary school, but I slept for the first time in the same time. I
used to use it as a stick,
and I liked vegetables that I used as a stick.
And doing 3 rolls professionally
is still from high school, but I think I started as an adult at that time.
At the time, if
you were doing art, silver is easy to live with, so
it’s a difficult gem, so let’s call it at all
.
I matched the channel and my parents did it while it was romantic, and it was silver 000 won. I wrote it with all my heart. How did my
wish come true, I
ate it with patience, but it was
close to 90, Jessie Se-hee, and
he died after a long life.
It was a tool for writing that was leaking to keep it down for the rest of my life, so that I
could write a letter or write something about the purpose of uh n or nsa
.
It's the same as drawing a good picture and looking at it. I put
better content on it
and my heart's low tone ca
n't come. Uh
Kim Jung
I wrote the work because my emotions were put on it, but
it makes the viewer feel it too.
Saliva follows prey
You're pretty and you're so big.
You have a heart. You
're just a man. The person who made the brush while
staying at home is Ulsan Kim Jong-wook, who is the teacher of Chung, and
it's Umbrella's Intangible Cultural Festival.
The representative couple will have to iron the freebies to meet another good 4th round.
Yes, especially today, Bang Yong
Soo, who is working as a national exhibition writer in Daegu,
will talk about
designing a little bit of pungmul
[Music]
It does
n't
feel right if I sit down, it's solid 1 It'll be fine,
so it all comes out under me
Hey, I'm in
a situation where
I've been educated I've been educated by reading
more songs, I can eat one more drink,
but I went to the
training  Lush, really hard, a little probe
Nautica,
something really bad, I hear it
as I go on. The
new year is the scholastic’s job, so there’s nothing
more that needs to be done.
As a hansang, it
is shared at each event venue, and even if given by the National Assembly,
many events are seen
and received.
[Music] Uh, the
tin trade experiments that were not made in Yeongam
will use the experiments.
Ssireum is the representative traditional folklore of Korea
.  Especially when it comes to tin
trading experiments,
I think it really means more and
talk about people who see
some [ __ ] ants
on the
spot.  to act
Living emotions are also bitter
.
I’m unfolding them as more wonderful
[music]
uh ah
ah
tae
[music]
woo
uh ah
ceo 5
222 uh
0 uh uh
[music]
5 uh
[music] uh
to
be
will be
5 uh
tel
[music]  ]
U
[Music]